five museums are crowded onto an island
in the river spray the most popular is
the Pergamon Museum it's under
renovation until 2019 but the south wing
is still open so museum goers can see
the market Gate of Miletus and the
Ishtar Gate from Babylon two of the most
famous surviving ancient structures the
museum Islands colonnaded courtyard is
an oasis of tranquility surrounding the
outer Knutson art gallery the old
National Gallery this museum houses
paintings and sculptures from the 19th
century
then as the neues museum it suffered
heavy damage in World War two and
restoration only began in 2003 the
result is a composite of old and new the
ravages of history only complement the
building's charm one of the stars of a
noiseless aelion's collection is the
bust of Egyptian Queen Nefertiti I felt
like maybe I was in an Egyptian
courtyard I'm a big fan of the British
Museum and I've been to the Smithsonian
but this place is unique I love it
I wish we had more time to spend here
and to see all of them but we are very
impressed
every Sunday evening in summer crowds
gather at the border museum at the
islands northern tip
these openers summer concerts are free
and growing in popularity
you